but you know chris i'm wondering
i how you see as you said you've been
covering lebron for a long time 10th
finals appearance for him
where do you put this current team uh in
how do you even characterize this this
current lakers team compared to the
other
nine lebron finals teams that you've
seen
man i don't want to diminish what this
team is doing uh
but you look at those teams all right
the miami heat teams they don't compare
to any of those miami teams
that team that won you know came back
from 3-1 deficit beat the golden state
wars
they're not better than that team this
this right here is
this this right here
you know it's probably one of the and i
hate to use this word
but it is you know it's probably the
weakest
championship team he's been on just from
top to bottom it's not you can't compare
it to those to those other three titles
he's won but with that being said
you know
the all the obstacles that they have to
face everything they have to go through
this season um you can't diminish them
whatsoever but when you you know when
you're ranking them i i don't think it
even compares to the three titles
do you make pics chris
or you are you stay away from i know
some people stay away from them
unfortunately i do i try to stay away
from it but my job asked me to do it you
know so okay i won't i want to ask you
for a pick i guess i'll say
somebody on this set
has picked the heat in six somebody is
coming at the king
and i know when you come at the king
your best not miss so somebody has
picked the heat in six so can you tell
that somebody as in me
uh what the heat have to do to make me
look smart
well look i'll say this if the heat pull
this off
i wouldn't be surprised because i said
from the beginning guys i was like the
way this setup is no home court
advantage or anything like that
it's set up for some type of team that
we didn't see coming at all to come and
just steamroll through here and steal a
championship
and i could see that with the miami with
that being said i've already been been
public since yesterday and said i got
the lakers
yeah so
i put that out there but
miami look man
lebron can't lose he can't lose this
championship there you know this this is
he's
really
because i'll tell you rarely does he go
into a championship of finals
as the favor he's the favorite
in his finals and this is his former
team and all i know i know there's only
one player that's still a part of that
team that was you know with him during
the heroes run that she's done his
hassle and he's not even playing but
it's still a pat riley
guided team
and the way things ended
miami and lebron
they didn't end on the cleanest of terms
and so
pat riley would want nothing more
but to take down lebron his first time
getting back to the finals with the
lakers and so for all those reasons
right there lebron cannot lose this
against this former team
i don't expect them to i i i think the
heater are worthy opponent i'm giving
them two games some people may say
that's even disrespectful but hey
lebron's favorite i i think they'll get
it